okay guys it's your boss psychobabble
and today we're playing a little game
called no way
okay um I don't really know much about
this game in fact I don't even know what
the healthy Idol is supposed to be it's
a balance room something we may be the
opposite is like an evil sister version
I don't really know
um but we're gonna we're gonna play this
okay I don't think I can do that my
house at this at home but no it's a
horror game totally a dollar on Steam
and so I kind of like these little one
off guys um don't know much about it but
we're gonna find out let's do this yeah
Oh hard core
hmm enhancer get in there
oh that burns that burns oh my god I
hear but sand falling come back home
okay yeah it's just try no you know I
left
oh sweet home a lot huh
oh it's cool it's weird use the mask
lift actually knock so it's a
questionable idea to call someone this
late okay
that's 11 o'clock at night too late now
time to have a rest I guess I was asleep
but I like good night okay I mean it's
night night I guess at that time hmm
little KX flying right outside had fun
no my sleeping
thank God I don't know if I set up my
bedpan get up it's time right what the
hell there's a weird delay so like to
click on it and then now it's fast
actually silence let's just say it's a
blank piece of paper
darkness cloudy outside locked makes no
sense so why do you wait to get down
over there stole up strange stretch but
am I locked in here
no one I guess there's nothing to do
except sleep right well so try to get it
how's that sack how place I've chopped
it's a habit
do you hear it what that's right oh hey
that person leave just a bad dream
okay I guess I go back to sleep then I
guess it's time to say get the hell back
to sleep okay yeah hello pretty pretty
flat I know if I like how flat it is
usually gets me bad neck cramps you know
what I'm saying
yeah bad neck equals a bad day wake up
oh yeah it's time it's a time grab a
stop so I got an hour of sleep
night-night now are the fun
there's definitely what was riding on
this one now it still locked
whatever it was it's gone now stay away
why the thing stay away from this thing
what thousand here right there why is
that it was here how's that said always
an operon sorry
any other word hold on how about black
can't see anything nothing
mm-hm it is definitely something there
what gonna pay suck it
holy crap is like a heartbeat like that
I've no back this light well I try to
get a slight it has widened it take in a
little bit right Wow
well what's that the hell that yeah hey
Jess iPad your own strengths Apple II
just had the wall do it locked coming
it's so dark in here
there's definitely something there holy
cannoli oh it holy Snuggies hoc that I
go back to sleep
I've gone back to sleep hence while I
administer it just tired okay
please be Martin click be like not
hangin with sunlight
and I'm sleeping a lot now wake up it's
time I bang it it's time for school
Henrietta's class about forget dark
again guess what
how is that don't open there's not to
find out what it is still here the hole
is huge down dude why did is that glory
all there for my penis in there or no no
okay not to find out what it is
oh [ __ ] leave I'm writing now it's I
can't let it I coming a hole coming in
the hole glory hole well put out the
[ __ ] is that mean
and if I just keep on clicking on it
sunrise darkness strain silence damn the
ground
how's that noise that's the end near it
holy cannoli hole
Harley swaps
hit that it's sanded it just a bad dream
do you hear a whole something of those
hide penis penis nothing just a dream
huh
no way out of here holy cow no Willie
it's all it's huge
like five minutes was it fit in there
once easy buddy
now don't touch don't touch
birth something
what is dripping right getting tip is
that mean I'm getting tired so much you
need a sleep okay Oh like cannoli soon
sunrise huh my yeah this these wet
dreams are getting worse and worse every
day
every day you know how these Ziploc bags
I gotta throw a lot it's expensive even
the valet packs aren't aren't to make it
any easier
I got a Sam's Club and just say like all
right like I see her how to sit black
bags do you have any like garbage bags
or anything like because I can tell
tonight's gonna be a bad one you know I
can tell I'm good morning I don't like
morning that was like pitch black in
here Pat ream over sunrise heavy fog hmm
do your hair
[ __ ] shadow like guy outside lots of
but absolutely no more closet how
economy
holy [ __ ] let's get this SH out of me
Oh eNOS halt no way yeah that that
reality deserves absolutely normal
closet oh [ __ ]
this hole is biggest [ __ ] stay I [ __ ] oh
oh oh whoa sir
sir there's our first our first patron
president huh
right you are not only have my [ __ ]
prison
I'm definitely prison Nona's coming hole
crawl crawl it did it here
whoa it turning me to sleep
I did not through the bed I wonder if
I'm actually in prison no way going
crazy
captivity
Wow does anyone know what happened
ellipsis underscore blinking look out
okay the [ __ ] hole in the wall but
someone gonna fix this hole I don't have
to call for like room service something
in Scent hey I call it I get [ __ ] a
holler place that's coming hole crawl it
did it here sorry muttering sorry
something then it open well this thing's
like opening I think did you see
oh yeah so something is wrong once they
come out I'm waiting for ya I got my
chapstick oh my god couldn't dig ain't
thinking think let in let it in alive
inside closet oh my god anything oh my
god
whoa what what am I going in it poof
something did not like me looking at
that trying to get inside that hole what
is it times we got really moving
well let me sleep someone is like out
there did a sweeping well it opens like
a second
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
one of the [ __ ] I had yeah yeah
where the [ __ ] am I supposed to go
that's how it's coming in
how do you think it igano
I'm getting croaked I'm getting probed
Oh No wow that panic in a second phrase
oh [ __ ] I'm like in the darkness right
now just walking around
whoa the mouse cursor is gone get it up
get help coming my shorter seriously
stay away no it's inside
don't open right yeah it's like moist in
there what to say
dumbass coming sorry you are you still
sorry I hope you're ill there's a why
don't you hate well whoa holy [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] I think a huge closed now
closing
I try to cause that Chad it closed you
were the raw egg
hey sir
I brought it I brought it I brought it
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] [ __ ] hello Daniel
take it get it get it up ah I'm gonna
traffic I was actually on the floor
something huh six [ __ ] huge it says
why it is something kind the door how do
I get it to like get more away from the
door tell if getting more away from the
door
that's that
so yeah see when you pick up the phone
it like moves let's try to close that
check in word okay I'm going in we're
going it says don't go outside I'm
crawling through the hole I'm crawling
yeah like a beeping again dare your hair
huh Shep oh okay I'm in the hole
okay now if you could see this [ __ ]
darker [ __ ] something potato something
what's right I can't see [ __ ] in here
they tell me I moved the cursor till I
can barely hear thinking now I can't see
[ __ ] [ __ ] crawl the sound now I'm
just constants today chef Hopkins I'm
just going straight
I hear something I just want to go back
to sleep I'm freaking tired
close down inward okay okay how about
that oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] steep down
here okay
doesn't seem safe but I did it follow
the sound
careful
holy [ __ ] something in the darkest [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he's coming after me okay hey so sad
it's just after I touch those things
think it this way
oh yeah
holy to Nelly there's next one
it's freaking hard dude oh uh Anxi sorry
well he's closest close holy God holy
canítö holy Toledo
oh there I don't get we're supposed to
do
does it have to go and turn off all
these things I don't know if that's it
[ __ ] getting confusing okay this one
over there
is this what I'm supposed to be doing
I'm following all these things but utter
I know
okay here's next one so far away think
that's one
hello Lee Toledo
what the [ __ ] oh I keep running into
them seriously how many more of these
things I did there well I'm at tunnel
now so many of this at the end you're
showing right after so it's dark why
this one's bigger I don't know such huge
getting close
[ __ ] is this can't move a lot huh try to
get that can't get frozen oh my god
they're like owls
that cats wait yeah hey hey hey Oh going
up I think okay
you can't strike huh what the hell's
going on here
wait what hey wait
I don't know what this is hella below is
about and I did not sign up with us if I
dead accidentally I'd like to cancer
waste think we want
I can't worry that fast okay okay I
gotta correct that my weight right one
oh the whole the butthole is a yo-yo why
is he on that site now tells us about
say this is not a dream alright then
I'll get the hell out of here
I'd like to get out of here he afraid ya
ain't gonna sleep all right yeah
[ __ ] open it okay I hope I that I try to
open it his calling me coming huh
holy Toledo
Rob thank you so loud I got back pest
light actually what I changed my boxers
hair back this night
holy smokes
he got me what what the heck of that
give it to him
mm-hmm consent plays like a [ __ ] okay
yeah I flush it say here
whoa it's all scratched up
do I have to like ferret away to escape
he's laughing at ya now he [ __ ]
better sleep now check my frickin bed
away
J SAS
well getting smaller the whole room
that's Clyde to get out get out of here
Bethany I'm stuck again in bed Bethany
on I was in the closet is this the
camera like sexuality what soap clothes
no no take him not I know it's they're
just gonna call him
escape
chase now day your sake no Blair how
small stood a deaf [ __ ] out of here
I like box it's closed what hey
holy smokes I'm just trying to you know
keep the lights on you know okay freakin
dark now I can't see [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ] is that what is that
oh it's a ceiling oh holy this is
getting trippy as hell this way what oh
I'm trying to go this way
yeah at the [ __ ] press n is the thing my
person
Oh like a needle
hey guillotine that we do you think you
know I feel like I've been a lot of
insults are flying at me and I feel like
I don't really deserve that hardcore
mode has been locked for this version
it'll be added soon just later updates
Wow okay that was that you wait he's
that that I think it's just a game
weird I don't know if I like how it
didn't really explain um was anything um
I thought it was gonna be that keep was
turning out to be like in prison or
something
and it was just like gonna be like a
powerful statement about like mental and
assim presence but no not the fact that
was really don't know I know interesting
game only the hearts team I recommend it
to play cool okay yeah yeah thanks for
watching yeah
[Music]